Туристичний потік до Криму минулого року
буцімто збільшився на 10%,
і на анексованому Росією півострові відпочило
7,5 мільйонів туристів, стверджує так званий
"глава Криму" Сергій Аксьонов.
Він називає українців з материкової частини
держави лідерами серед "іноземних туристів"
і запевняє, що їх приїхало близько одного мільйона
ста тисяч осіб. Аксьонов глузує, що це - цитата -
"народне голосування громадян сусідньої країни
щодо визнання російського статусу Криму".
Адже до окупантів, мовляв, у гості не їздять.
До окупації Криму Росією півострів щорічно
відвідували приблизно 5,5-6 мільйонів туристів.
Із них 4,5 мільйони приїздили з материкової України.
Ще мільйон-півтора - з Росії. Нині ж, заявляючи
про мільйон туристів із України, так званий
"глава Криму" Сергій Аксьонов посилається
на окупаційне Міністерство курортів і туризму Криму.
Аби перевірити ці дані, DW звернулася
до колишнього міністра курортів і туризму
Автономної Республіки Крим Олександра Лієва,
який керував туристичною галуззю до окупації.
За його даними, півострів прийняв цього року
лише 130 тисяч туристів, які перетнули
адміністративний кордон Херсонської області з Кримом.
А загалом, за даними Лієва, який нині очолює
Асоціацію індустрії гостинності України,
анексований півострів прийняв у 2019 році
не 7,5 мільйонів туристів, як рапортує Аксьонов,
а лише мільйон-півтора.
Методику розрахунку, яку використовують в Україні
останні 20 років, розробляли в Криму ще до анексії.
Ця методика складається з багаторічних
соціологічних досліджень та спеціальної формули,
завдяки якій вираховують, скільки саме людей
із пасажиропотоку є туристами. Нині певні
показники дещо скоригували, враховуючи анексію півострова.
Український пасажиропотік у Крим складається
з трьох основних категорій. Переважна більшість -
це ті, хто їде до своїх родичів або в особистих справах,
для вирішення побутових питань чи оформлення документів.
Друга категорія - ті, хто відвідує Крим
із оздоровчою метою. Клімат півострова для них є
етапом щорічного лікування. І третя категорія - це,
власне, ті, які їдуть саме для пляжного відпочинку.
Лише другу і третю категорії можна розцінювати
як відпочинковий туризм, і кількість таких туристів
із материкової України становить не більше
150-200 тисяч на рік після анексії Криму Росією.
Як повідомили DW у Держприкордонслужбі України,
пасажиропотік на адміністративній межі
з тимчасово окупованою територією Криму
минулого року загалом і в літні місяці зокрема
був приблизно на рівні 2018-го.
Прикордонники зазначають, що попри фейкові
заяви у російських ЗМІ про масовий наплив туристів
із материкової частини України,
переважна більшість подорожувальників - зовсім не туристи.
На думку Олександра Лієва та інших експертів,
Аксьонов видає за "туризм" кількість майже всіх
перетинів адмінкордону. За такою логікою виходить,
що одна людина, яка, приміром, з’їздила туди-сюди
5 разів за рік у власних справах,
щоб відвідати родичів чи для оформлення документів,
у "статистиці" Аксьонова генерувала 5 туристів.
Крім того, збільшення туристичного потоку
з самої Росії теж є нелогічним. Як стверджують
аналітики, авіапотік, приміром, суттєво скоротився,
адже ціни на квитки зросли на 20-25%.
Це пов’язують із запуском мосту через Керченську протоку,
адже влада РФ припинила давати дотації
для авіасполучення з півостровом.
Автопотік через міст теж не компенсував цих втрат.
Експерти зауважують: навіщо росіянам, приміром,
із Саратова чи Волгограда, проїжджаючи
Краснодарським краєм, їхати ще далі в Крим,
якщо можна зупинитися на відпочинок у Сочі чи десь навколо.
Тим більше, що там є добра інфраструктура
з часів Олімпіади, ціни нижчі,
а ситуація з безпекою краща, ніж в анексованому Криму.
Майже половина росіян, які нині прибувають
на окупований півострів, - це відпочивальники
за соціальними путівками, переважно робітники
підприємств із віддалених куточків Росії.
Так заповнюють застарілі санаторії ще з радянською інфраструктурою.
Тим часом спектр туристичних цілей для українців
після запровадження безвізового режиму з ЄС
суттєво розширився. На додачу до Єгипту
і Туреччини вони дедалі більше переорієнтовуються
на курорти європейських країн, долетіти куди
лоукостами стає все доступніше.
Твердження так званого "глави Криму" Сергія Аксьонов
про те, що минулого року понад мільйон українців
відвідали півострів із туристичною метою,
є маніпулятивним. Так само, як і твердження
про "визнання українцями російського статусу Криму".
Адже переважна більшість тих, хто перетинає
адміністративний кордон між Херсонською областю і Кримом,
їдуть зовсім не на відпочинок, а в особистих справах.